this et exclusive kelty knight stopped
by spidey's home to get a sneak peek at
all the drama including
heidi's ongoing war with body shamers
it feels like it's acceptable and
allowed to talk negatively about my body
where if you did that about anyone else
people would be cancelled culture and
how dare you and it's not but for me
it's like oh it's heidi like i'm not
a human anymore which is infuriating
recently it was almost laughable because
i'm like you know what i have gained
weight in a pandemic
and i have drinking a little more and
eating a little more it feels
like the industry in general has wanted
to like
outcast me and make me negative and i'm
like is lauren conrad still paying you
all like what is going on
the 34 year old became the target of
tabloid speculation
that she was expecting after these
photos surfaced of a beach day with
spencer last month
she literally just ate the best lunch
drink all these margaritas
we didn't even call the paparazzi out
that way so that was even more annoying
you know
we've been trying since december so
hopefully this month or next month or
sooner than later we'll see spidey's
pregnancy journey plus all the drama on
season two of the hills new beginnings
which premieres tonight on mtv
there's romance brewing with brody
jenner and audrina patridge
brody and i we did kiss and with brody
and newly
single kristen cavallari i feel like
brody and kristen
almost hook up no spoiler alerts maybe
they do
brody and kristin i mean that's breaking
news i don't know well you do know that
brody and kristen were together for two
years before they
lived together like very serious spencer
lived with them
at casablanca and used to film their own
reality choices i got the footage
i don't want to get sued i have like the
original newlyweds
yeah so now that kristen has returned to
the hills
will lauren return i'm sure if
the zeros all just kept going you could
get a lauren
appearance any day i'm just not sure
they feel there's that value
of no i'm just saying for for what it
would cost you could also get
you know a whole nother season jennifer
lawrence or
you know maybe blake lively
thanks to her fashion line lauren has an
estimated net worth of 40 million
dollars
as for how spencer and heidi are paying
the bills what are you doing to my
crystals
i'm selling them what no we could just
be
our careers being famous for nothing
that was a lot of fun and easy
i do miss out i didn't want to have a
business i didn't like the only reason
we have business side he's like you
can't buy any more crystals so
i was like can i sell something and
she's like yeah yours
you want to keep most of them well i
mean they go up in value
to me they're more you know they're like
bitcoin for instance like
i could have bought this table that she
said noted of all these kunzites for 15
000. a year ago she said we have money
and now that table is probably worth 150
000.
aquamarine from afghanistan supervised
by shfinah museum not at our house
is this expensive how much is this right
i mean let's not we don't want
anybody to crash no it's not
you